will be an astronomical price uh there
was a a senior leader of Hamas who was
interviewed a couple of days ago who
said that uh in his view we have enough
hostages to free all of our prisoners
all of the Palestinian prisoners being
held in Israeli jails there are about
5,200 Palestinian prisoners in Israeli
jails so they are looking at this as an
opportunity for the biggest prison or
release that anyone has ever secured in
Palestine to boost their own political
standing I don't see there being much
public appetite for that in Israel
people are still they're burying their
dead I don't think they're going to be
eager to make a deal with the group that
just killed 800 or more Israelis uh and
I think for the government there's going
to be a real concern about the precedent
this sets I mean if you reward what what
was the largest attack in Israel's
history with a mass prisoner release
you're all but inviting someone else to
try that again